يا شباب رقم واح
ينتصر وننتصر بس بدنا الصبر بس الصبر يا
اخوان اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم وزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه
تعلن ان الاحتلال ارتكب 17 مجزره بحق
العائلات في مناطق متفرقه بالقطاع خلال
الساعات ال4 الماضيه راح ضحيتها
249 شهيدا
و510 جرحه وحزب الله يعلن استشهاد وسام
طويل احد قادته العسكريين في غاره
اسرائيليه في جنوب لبنان تجدون المزيد من
اخبار حرب غزه في رابط بالتعليق الاول
الجيش الاوكراني يقول ان روسيا شنت هجوما
صاروخيا واسع النطاق على مناطق عديده في
اوكرانيا في حين اعلنت السلطات الروسيه
اجلاء 300 من مواطنيها من مدينه بجرود في
روسيا قرب الحدود الاوكرانيه بسبب القصف
الاوكراني مجلس حقوق الانسان الباكستاني
يدين تعطيل خدمات الانترنت ووسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي في كل انحاء البلاد مع اطلاق
المعارضه حمله انتخابيه ووصفه بانه انتهاك
للقانون الدولي في وقت كان يستعد فيه حزب
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان لاطلاق
حمله ضخمه عبر الانترنت قبل الانتخابات
المقرره الشهر
المقبل الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
يعلن عن اسماء مرشحي حزب العداله والتنميه
لرئاسه 26 بلديه في تركيا بالانتخابات
المحليه المرتقبه والتي تلي في اهميتها
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه معلنا
ترشيح الوزير السابق والبرلماني الحالي
مراد قروم لبلديه اسطنبول
الى
اللقاء